soldiers on the streets of the Thai
capital taking up the battle against a
growing number of coronavirus cases
Thailand reported its biggest single-day
jumping infections led by those who
attended a boxing match at an
entertainment complex
earlier this month around 5,000 people
were among the crowds and have since
dispersed across the country there was
news about other people from the boxing
circle who was sick on that day the news
was headlining all over the place and I
was stressed as I realized I might have
it as I had never felt any of these
symptoms before the spike increases the
number of infections by 25% taking the
total passed the 400 mark from the start
of the year Thailand has been vigilant
in trying to keep high-risk visitors out
of its borders a tough call for a
country which relies on tourism and now
another setback to its economy as the
government imposes a partial shutdown of
its capital Singapore also reached a
grim milestone with the announcement of
its first two coronavirus fatalities on
Saturday there has been a surge in cases
this week but the Health Minister was
quick to reassure the nation
I know Singaporeans will be worried and
anxious we must take courage and not
give in to our fears we have announced a
series of safe distancing measures
yesterday and we must all take the
necessary precautions to keep ourselves
and our families safe in South Korea
slow down in infection rates this week
proved short-lived with 147 new cases
reported on Saturday South Korea is
still the second most affected country
in Asia behind China its rate of
infection is significantly down from the
peak at the end of last month but public
health officials warned that any
recovery remained fragile and cluster
infections could still emerge and
there's hung that he you may feel that
the current situation has improved a lot
compared to the past but we continue to
see group infections inflow from foreign
countries and mass outbreaks of various
workplaces
South Korea has been fighting the virus
through widespread testing without
resorting to the lockdowns and heavy
restrictions of movement which helped
China contain the spread life in China
is slowly returning to normal after
reporting no new local infections for a
third day but the authorities have
warned that imported cases have risen by
more than 200 percent this week with an
increase of dozens daily all from
overseas the government is taking
measures to screen and quarantine
passengers arriving into the country
many of them students from Europe or the
United States Hong Kong had managed to
prevent a rise in cases even at the peak
of the outbreak in China for the cities
now facing a surge in infections with a
number of cases more than doubling in a
week the rice was mostly due to
residents returning from overseas but
the government is highlighting another
issue people in Hong Kong have been
vigilant from the start on the streets
and in public places it's hard to find
someone that's not wearing a face mask
but after months of taking precautions
staying away from crowds and social
distancing many are now dropping their
guards and that the government says is
the biggest risk to the city and the
main reason they're expecting a second
wave of infections
Viveca pollen our Jazeera Hong Kong